well the key can certainly affect a lot
of things just like your body but plants
need specific help to withstand this
desert heat 8 news now reporter Brian
will takes us to the Garden shows us how
to take care of these plants during the
hot summer days
as we get deeper into summer that sun is
only getting hotter and hotter and it's
important for your plants like these to
not only survive the heat but to thrive
in it
Jennifer Mojica has been gardening in
Las Vegas since 2005. she's frequently
at places like Moon Valley Nursery I
have roses and I have an herb garden and
then I have a raised bed full of Summer
vegetables to keep her garden going
through the scorching temperatures takes
work and water at the right time and the
right amount according to Matthew vasara
at Moon Valley
I want to order three four five feet
down into the ground with a slow drip I
don't really want to use a hose and
different things like that because it's
not slow enough water watering comes
down to a specific cycle to help Roots
grow and spread deep it's all about the
cycle you want to get it nice and wet
and you want to let it dry out you
actually want the roots to actually go
look for water and be strong on their
own something else Mojica picked up over
her many years in the garden when
dealing with the hot temps mulch is the
mulch is the most important to keep
adding through the heat she adds mulch
to help protect her plants from dying
out too fast and even covers some of her
vegetables when it gets really hot as
for any plants that just sit out on your
balcony depends on your sun exposure
different things what I recommend is
really like a moisture meter or just
your finger stick it in the soil is it
wet how deep is it wet the most
important thing you need to remember to
keep your plants thriving this summer is
a watering schedule reporting in the
southwest Valley Ryan will eight news
now
and it is important that you stick to
the Southern Nevada water district
guidelines when Watering your garden and
trees it is prohibited between 11 and 7
pm and remember never water on Sundays